[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
my
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
well well well ladies and gentlemen
well well well
just when we thought
just what we thought
there wasn't going to be any news this
week
i have not seen the trailer
that's what's going to make this extra
fun i have not seen the trailer
by the way james i saw you said it's
your first time here welcome
thank you so much for stopping by
and hanging out let's see there was
somebody else grecky k just
uh i hadn't realized that wasn't even
subscribed
hey thank you so much yeah we just hit
uh 30k this week guys pretty awesome
pretty big milestone
but yeah i
i for those of you follow me on twitter
i had planned on doing like a chamber of
secrets let's play tonight while still
talking hogwarts legacy and stuff but
i've never played through the pc version
of the game
so i thought that might be fun
well then you know they just decided to
go drop a new trailer so here we are
so here
we are
ladies and gentlemen
people of the internet welcome
to retro reckons who are live i i
slightly adjusted the camera view if you
guys can't tell so my desk
has been moved back so you guys always
saw this wall right here
but i was like on the other side of the
room
i'm telling you man my wife thinks i'm
crazy it's just like
it's the one room of the house that's
like mine
so i change it up constantly i just it's
like
i think i've tried like every
configuration possible except for the
one that i have right now
except for the one that i have right now
i'll have to do like a little uh
have to do something sometime like a
video where you guys can see it a little
better
all right trying to pin my
no not a man not quite a man cave it's
like my office so
sometimes i work from home too
acoustics are better interesting
i did some
uh
i tweaked a little bit with the um
i don't really actually i'm trying to
think
hey johnny with the tier one welcome
dude thank you so much
you know what i just realized i don't
have the uh
[Music]
i'm telling you man like i changed up my
something like i updated obs and a lot
of my stuff is now missing so actually
looks like we got two members dr
robopanda
welcome thank you so much for becoming a
member as well and then also johnny
became a tier one member here
so yeah i've been somebody was saying
retro making last minute uh
updates no i actually i did the stream
elements thing after the uh
stream last week
and
thought i was set up and good to go and
it looks like stream ellen's is now
added
but
the commands aren't quite working right
let me see if this one works
[Music]
maybe
okay unlike special perks and emo
support retro okay so that one works but
the one with the um
oh that's pretty cool so stream elements
also has
whoa
calm oh potato posted it again i was
like calm down stream elements
calm down so those uh those who just
joined dr robo panda and johnny that is
what that is about it's different
terminology from twitch but um
yeah so i think i lost my uh alerts on
this page let me go here
and i would need to add let's see
it's like whenever there whenever you
can feel people watching you do
something you know like how much harder
it is
like when somebody's over your shoulder
and you're like trying to teach someone
it's like
you all of a sudden forget how to do it
that's where i'm at right now
i'm trying to remember okay wait let me
let me think here it's not a uh display
capture
it's going to be
no it's not a window capture either it's
browser there we go browser browser
browser
okay we don't want
uh
we don't want any of these things
actually so
alerts might be broken actually let me
try i'm gonna switch scenes here
[Music]
how are you
yes
scenes are working or uh
scenes
whatever whatever these things are
called they're working here
[Music]
working on this page all right so we'll
just we'll just keep it on this one then
welcome to the new subs welcome to the
new members oh no now it's just like
it's like they were all saved
so they're catching up now
oh man wizardphd yo what is up
wizardphd coming in with the raid
daddy merlin ladies and gentlemen
so i don't know if that's something to
do with the trailer or not i have no
idea i've not seen the trailer
we're getting ready to watch it live
wizardphd thank you so much for the raid
guys uh professor lynette on twitter aka
wizardphd another fellow hogwarts legacy
content creator i saw her the other day
playing um lego harry potter on uh on
youtube here go check her out really
cool channel really awesome breakdown
breakdowns of hogwarts legacy so welcome
aboard everybody welcome aboard you're
gonna lose your mind
let's okay let's uh let me pull up one
thing for you guys here so
i started this little newsletter thing
it's like it's kind of through twitter
it's pretty cool how if you already have
twitter you can do this newsletter 171
of you subscribe thank you so much so
i've just been posting like little
weekly updates i try to do them sunday
monday that time frame
and so in my newsletter
this week it was like what's next for
hogwarts legacy
so i'll be honest i thought we were
gonna have a little bit of a lull here
things kind of slow down a bit
that's what i talk about here but then
right down here i say the playstation
showcase if it ever happens
the most logical time to learn about
playstation exclusives a sony event or
at the very least a special trailer like
the duelsense one or even a playstation
blog post ladies and gentlemen we got
both tonight
we got both
so
whenever they first announced this state
of play so this actually was not a big
playstation showcase it was like a
20-minute stay to play so i tweeted
yesterday and oh man don't worry i'm not
going to go through all the
i'm not going to go through all the
replies i'm not going to call all you
guys out
because there were so many people like
no way no way no way it's not happened
not happening i was like i don't think
it's likely i agree
but
but but remember our pal chandler wood
community manager chandler wood
had said
playstation exclusives
more information
soon
soon now chandler knows in the video
game industry we all know like soon
it could be a week it could be a day it
could be a month
could be like six months soon
so i did think there was a chance a lot
better chance than most people think i
wouldn't have um
i wouldn't have said likely but i would
have said way higher chance than
everybody else everybody else was like
no way no way no way it's not gonna be
there
but i'm not gonna call you guys out i'm
not gonna do that
so uh yeah it uh if you guys have missed
it
i was i was on twitter i saw like i love
here's what i love about twitter there's
a lot of things i don't like about
twitter
what i love about twitter is when news
like this breaks
you guys were just like the tags were
were crazy man
i just started getting tagged like crazy
left and right
oh yeah the mic does uh somebody who's
saying the mic's a little bit high i bet
it lost my uh
oh yeah i know why i know why let me
turn this down a bit
you're a wizard harry
let's try it at about
plus five
check check check still a little peeking
welcome to the new uh subscribers by the
way guys thank you so much
see i'm telling you this is what happens
when you move your setup dude
like all i had to do was shut down my
computer and unplug it and now
somebody did say acoustics sound better
it's probably i just sounded much louder
okay let's try plus four db
check check
one two there should be a limiter on as
well so if i get too loud it doesn't uh
peak like crazy
and i'm also really like stuffy right
now man i i honestly didn't know if i
was gonna be able to stream today
because i was so
congested i have really bad allergies
hey actually look look there's with your
phd right there in my little recommended
over here
you love to see it
audio good now okay nice
the mighty okay i gotta i gotta let me
go through the comments here
you guys are commenting like crazy i got
a shout out we got niko in the house
fandom draws
wanted me to shout out amore poet i
don't think amory poet will be here
tonight
uh aether or ether i'm not sure how
that's pronounced welcome gm games
johnny what's up dude lucked out and got
a ps5 for me and my kid brother at
launch nice dude
let's see we already talked about gm
games uh stream elements ladies and
gentlemen shreem ellen's elements is
here tonight and they're just like
banning people left and right my
apologies dutch and there was someone
else i haven't seen them comment again
they're probably like this guy's crazy
oh my apologies i'm trying to figure fix
the stream elements filter and it was
just being a little aggressive there
we got feathers in the house as well
uh james we shout out james earlier
phsp126 welcome logan is back i remember
your name logan shadow guide
channel member is here as well retro guy
gaming
like after retro i'm so used to saying
retrorecontour that's why i kind of like
choked for retro
retro guy gaming
another channel member welcome welcome
np is here says give it to me
i think to talk about the game you guys
what do you think i think they're
talking about the game afflicted affy
affy first time catching live stream
please don't be gentle also i love your
videos enthusiasm for the game excited
for it need to play oh i'm pumped too
such a slither okay there is dutch all
right so dutch
dutch is out of time out
dutch is back in
what was so funny is their comment was
like i think duchess was something like
um about fable4
and then the other person was just like
hi what's up retro what
why did stream elements time this out
yeah and then the uh exclamation point
commands exclamation point viewers
i also think it doesn't play 100 nice
with youtube versus twitch i think
that's another piece of this
madeleine welcome how's it going
oh dutch is actually a ravenclaw
all right all right we got hollow knight
and then oh i think hollow knight was
the other one
my apologies dutch and hollow knight
been watching the afflicted says been
watching rewatching the harry potter
movies lately to get all the info i need
for the game neurolink good that i don't
sleep these days from the uk oh man i
know every time i stream at this hour
the uk peeps are like
retro come on dude
we can't make it at this hour
trust me if i ever um as i've said
before if i'm ever doing this whole
youtube thing full time then streams
will be much earlier actually
actually i might do a stream early in
the day on friday maybe play like harry
potter chamber of secrets or something
because it's just a random day i had
taken off like a vacation day so my kids
are going to be in school
have the house to myself so it's like
hey this might be a good day to hop on
do a little stream we'll see we'll see
stay tuned if you um
follow me on twitter and you're on the
youtube then you'll see on the little
community page i'll post there
we got shadow guide another channel
member is here as well jp ravenfire
welcome oh this hashtag daddy merlin
thing brick plays how's it going
uh i think we got levi already mr joker
senpai skylines music james again
let's see look jay rossi is in the house
as well potter legacy channel member
hollow knight oh yep we already uh
shouted out i feel like hollow knight
deserves extra shout outs hollow knight
in dutch because you know
that little
please just forgive me for that little
mix up there at the beginning
that's super another channel member
how's it going potato xd go ravenclaw
travis hammers here olamar 92. dude did
you see the new uh pikmin info
crazy day for games right we had a bunch
of crazy nintendo news too idk outcast
is here shadow win 925 is here zachary
is here
ignis quartz is here as well dr
robopanda we shouted out sanda panda
how's it going
dr evil to be anna silver thread
tom snipes is back with us again uh oh
dude nico is back to gifting the
memberships again oh my goodness nico
thank you so much ogb changing room
ladies it really like my my wife hates
change she hates it
she just hates it looks like chris
got the gifted membership there nice
thank you so much nico
no caps right on time exactly dude room
of requirement johnny with the two
dollar super chat today is your birthday
what
what a great birthday present dude
what a great birthday present man
hogwarts legacy is like hey we're
dropping a new uh trailer
dude thanks so much for the super chat
thanks so much for all your support
johnny i always see you uh showing love
on twitter and on the videos as well
very much appreciated
yeah exactly hollow knight it's like the
room becomes whatever i need so i can
just shift things around i think will be
awesome speaking of the room
see how like this is like a corner right
here
i want to get like one of those corner
shelving units
that goes from about
right in here
to like over there maybe like a double
layer actually like a double shelf
that'd be a great spot for like
i don't know potter memorabilia
video game goodies like my little uh
oh i don't have links over on the other
side of the room now you guys remember
link used to be in the background he's
on the other side so i had to move him
tom snipes didn't expect a new trailer
today i thought
i thought there was a much better chance
than everybody else was saying but
yeah i wouldn't have guessed it like i
wouldn't have said it's definitely
happening here because there's still so
much time before the release of the game
jason hodges another channel member
jason what is up
yo shadow 44 with a 10 super chat shadow
thank you so much let's see your channel
is helping me cope my unhealthy level of
hype
please don't stop making videos
hey i can uh i can definitely keep that
going shadow
i will definitely keep that going thank
you so much for your support on the
channel thank you for the super chat
uh we haven't even gotten to the trailer
yet guys we haven't even gotten to the
trailer
if you're just dropping in now you
haven't missed it i have not watched it
yet see man look look like i'm like you
know what i'm not gonna watch it i want
i want to experience with the with the
community here i don't want to look at
it beforehand so that's what we're doing
here we're gonna we're gonna watch it
and we're gonna i'm you guys are gonna
see my live reaction and if you haven't
seen it then hey you'll get to
react in real time too but yeah man
thank you so much for the chat
macy is here as well cr creesh tabob
like the lights yeah
the light looks pretty good i think i
might move it down though i'm a weird i
hate like wires showing
so the wire
i don't like it i don't like it showing
so i might just drop it down a bit
um
and then you also can't see like this
little uh
ikea thing right
here like this pegboard it's got some
metroid stuff on there but
it's a work in progress who knows next
week i might be
completely in a completely new spot
you'll have to see
yeah macy exactly dude i did not see
your comment macy before i was talking
about the the shelves
uh james says do sound clear today
though compared to recordings camera
seems a touch blurry uh i think it might
be
it could be the lighting
because now where i'm a lot closer to
the um
i'm a lot closer to the wall here i
might need to adjust the lights a little
bit
and i'm also as i said i'm way under the
weather everything reviews uh i'm
american yeah if you i mean if you can't
tell by the voice
b freshness welcome how's it going
potato
uh jake is back jake what's up dude mr
seven digit we got drummer boy here
not spoiling people are 50 50 on the new
trailer well if it's what i'm thinking i
know i know about the playstation
exclusivity part but maybe there's
another reason that people are 50 50.
morgan welcome thanks for stopping by
morgan nightly nerd is here ready to own
a shop this february ooh tease tease
tasbert is back welcome
grecky and we already uh wizard oh man
i'm way behind on comments wizardphd
tessa zone m we got neville here all
right guys if you ask a question my
apologies i'm just gonna run through
shout out the names get caught up in
chat and then we're gonna watch the
trailer here
uh we got let's see okay a lot of these
are repeat names now all right good
jason the king
welcome how's it going jerry harmony
bells t
eddie chaos one up vr
joshua ellington joshua how's it going
rita flair hey i remember rita
i've seen rita in some other streams i'm
pretty sure might have been wizard phd
might have been there
steven rice channel member welcome
steven how's it going
i gotta be hold on what is this
creative cartamency nice welcome
let's see we got okay
adhd k1d vlogs welcome hi iq warrior
that's a name i recognize welcome back
dylan what's up dylan didn't think it
would happen happy to be wrong yeah i
mean a lot of people didn't
and to be 100 fair i wouldn't have put
money on it happening but i just thought
people were being way too far the other
way like
saying no way a thousand percent no way
mike there's a chance guys there's a
chance soon could mean five minutes ago
exactly
exactly
all right alex is here as well you
haven't missed anything alex just some
shout outs just some laughs
tone 83 duarte channel member welcome
back
and there's another channel member oni
savior coming in with the two dollar
super chat oni how's it going man we got
a new trailer to break down
jonathan what's up dude
that's my real name actually if you guys
didn't know
it's my real name
brady moss soundtrack
and
another uh another few um
subscribers welcome oh yeah small
small buttons we're going to get to the
blog for sure
all right i see oh i see another nikko
we got two nikkos in the house now lucas
little t cramming william
jenna
guy perfect
had to look at that one twice i was like
is that guy prefect
kanso welcome
all right
melissa yes i do remember you melissa
showing lots of generosity with the
super chats welcome back
all right here we go here we go here we
go first thing i need to do
nope do not play
let's mute our music if you guys want to
check this music out celtic medieval
tavern non-copyright volume three
it is a relaxation harmony youtube
all right so
wait what are they calling this one
all right you know what else i might uh
yeah yeah yeah let's let's um
we'll do a little youtube intro here
to go with this as well
say hi to youtube everybody
your your chat comments will include
this oh you know what else i need to hit
record to
start recording hopefully my pc doesn't
go crazy and start dropping frames check
check check one two
i think we're still good
hi youtube yeah there we go
people of the internet what is up
retrorecons who are here and we are
getting ready to react live to the new
hogwarts legacy the haunted hogsbeat
shop playstation exclusive quest this is
my very first time seeing the trailer
and we are reacting live here with the
chat
right now
i hear it's dark
ooh okay hogsmeade madame mason i
understand you have a shop to sell
i think you will find my germs quite
madame mason
what's the catch
you are wise to be wary
why is your mistress selling the shop
dude this game is so creepy
i don't trust her the lady talking
yo what before you just could not seem
to escape the darkness
oh my goodness
they're actually using those little uh
dummy characters
watch
wait was that the joker
what
okay wait wait wait the haunted hogs
meet shop playstation exclusive quest
includes additional dungeon
so this is a whole entire dungeon
shopkeepers cosmetic set and in-game
hogsmeade shop
say what
dude is this surely this is not only the
deluxe is it only the deluxe
is it only okay wait playstation
exclusive quest ps5 ps4
the haunted hogsmeade shop quest is
exclusive to playstation consoles
through february 10 2024. okay there you
go good news bad news for the
pc and xbox folks there and nintendo
switch
it looks like the game
it is not totally exclusive it is a
timed exclusive which we thought it
could be
but oh my goodness
that was creepy
dude everything like all the new stuff
coming out about this game they are
going all in on the dark arts
wow
super impressed we're definitely gonna
have to do a full breakdown of that
trailer at some point
for those of you watching live like
right now
but as always thank you all so much for
watching
i'll talk to you again soon
wow okay
what
what
all right let's just dive right back in
i'm gonna watch it over
again that's step one and we're probably
uh let's see it's only a minute let's
watch it at normal speed one more time
then we'll start slowing it down okay so
we got hogsmeade
and then hogs hit okay
i gotta calm down i can't just let it
play i need to stop i need to actually
do what i said and let it play through
tasman boo
get spooked tasman with the five dollar
super chat thank you so much free
support
dude yeah this is okay i was not well we
the haunted hogsmeade thing was kind of
leaked
i can't remember where exactly
it was like the day that the pre-orders
went live that we heard about the
haunted hogsmeade thing
so i can't remember where exactly but
this is you know confirmation of it
hello madame what is that in honeydew
i think you will find my germs quite
generous
what's the catch
you are wise to be wary
why is your mistress selling the shop
she has had rotten bad luck with the
last few tenants
those who came before you just another
voice you're a wizard
hagrid's in the game what
dude was that morgana
you're a wizard
oh my gosh man
german translation gotcha
right it is so dark
okay i do have to find out let me go and
read the playstation blog so i'm fully
up to date on all the same news that you
guys are
uh let's see here it is so if you guys
missed this chandler wood tweeted this
out in addition to the trailer they made
the a new blog post here so here we go a
dark secret awaits and hogwarts legacy's
haunted hogsmeade playstation exclusive
quest which we've now learned is for one
year of exclusivity so good news bad
news there for the xbox pc and switch
folks you will get to play it just going
to be waiting a year so hopefully the
game is long let's say you won't have to
worry about it but hey i mean it's like
fresh new content a year in you'll be
able to look forward to that
all right here we go
will you brave the darkness that lies
beneath the haunted hogs meat shop
see how long this is first
oh this is a pretty oh my okay this is
pretty lengthy
all right it's pretty lengthy post here
okay the past few weeks have been
exciting for all of us here at avalanche
software we have announced hogwarts
legacy will launch on february 10 2023
actually february 7th if you pre-order
deluxe
we officially opened pre-orders and
revealed the different editions you can
get and we set the mood with a trailer
that shows you a glimpse at just how
dark hogwarts legacy can get when you
explore what lurks in the shadows we
also attended the wizarding worlds back
to hogwarts celebration to announce the
much requested ability to bring your
house and wand into the game by linking
your harry potter fan club and warner
brothers games accounts which will also
unlock some exclusive fan cosmetics i'm
eager to be seamlessly sorted into the
right into slytherin in the game without
question along with my wand a 14 inch
pliant beach wood with unicorn hair core
if you were wondering before we get into
new announcements i want to talk a
little bit about sebastian sallow's dark
legacy
watch with captions oh yeah that's a
good idea oni thank you so much for the
super chat as well
sebastian salaz's dark legacy okay so
this is the one that we got at uh
gamescom
sebastian quickly became a beloved
character since he was first revealed as
a classmate in the hogwarts legacy state
of play last march we've been thrilled
with the reaction to this charismatic
slytherin if you're a fan of sebastian
you're not alone nearly everyone at
avalanche loves sebastian too creating
the sebastian sallow's dark legacy
trailer gave us the opportunity to show
a darker side of hogwarts legacy while
giving you another glimpse into sebs as
we at the studio have come to call him
story
after we showed avodah kadava in march
many of you wondered if the other uh oh
uh uh oh if the other unforgivable
curses would be in the game this trailer
highlights the cruciatus curse in an
ominous decision that you'll need to
make as a player will you be the one to
cast crucio the torture curse on your
friend or will you have sebastian cast
it on you
what circumstances lead you to this
moment undertaking seb's companion
questline will put you in these
harrowing situations where no choice is
an easy one oh dude i thought he was
about to confirm oh wait wait wait maybe
he is i was like is he about to confirm
imperio
moreover sebastian's companion questline
like those of nats i and poppy is
entirely optional
dude where's the ravenclaw companion
chandler where's the ravenclaw companion
yet it explores an ever-present question
about the dark arts are they still evil
if they could save
a life oh i love that man i love that so
that's the line from sebastian about
some curses shouldn't be unforgivable or
something like that you know given given
the circumstances right if it can save a
life
i love that what a great like moral
dilemma they're trying to set up there
when coming up with the theme for this
trailer we knew we wanted it to focus on
the darker elements of the game and
sebastian's story immediately jumped to
the top of the list
oh man okay that's cool that's i mean
that's just shedding a little bit more
light on what we already knew about but
now here's the main new stuff here the
haunted hogs meat shop and we're not
done yet today we also have a peek at
the playstation exclusive quest the
haunted hogs meet shop this mysterious
quest is built into the core game and
can be discovered by any witch or wizard
playing on playstation okay good so it's
not just deluxe if you're playing on any
version of playstation you get it so
again exclusive quest additional dungeon
shopkeepers cosmetic and in-game hogs
meet shop
dude we get our own shop
cassandra mason that was the one of the
leaked names from way way way back
way back in our hogwarts legacy uh news
cycle cassandra mason has a shop to sell
you in hogsmeade but all is not as it
seems in this rundown establishment what
sinister secrets lie beneath madame
mason's shop and why was she so keen to
sell it that's a mystery hogwarts legacy
players will discover in the haunted
hogsmead shop quest exclusively
available on playstation platforms again
for one year
while i don't want to give too much away
about what strange things await players
below the shop overcoming these
challenges will reward you with a shop
of your own
what where you can sell items and gear
at better rates than anywhere else
and the shopkeepers cosmetics set a
right proper outfit for the
entrepreneurial hogwarts student
excuse me what
we can get our own shops in this game
are you kidding me
because this to me hints at
surely they wouldn't have a whole shop
that you can like become an entrepreneur
running
that wouldn't be the only way to get it
well this one yeah but
dude
they are going all in with the cosmetics
for this game man
all in
additionally if you pre-order any ps4 or
ps5 version of hogwarts legacy you'll
gain access to the felix felicis potion
recipe
felix felicis dressing that three times
fast is a luck potion that reveals gear
chests on the mini-map for one in-game
day
interesting okay
starting to get a little bit more
details on how
the time of the game might work day
night cycles all that sort of thing so
it is a luck potion that reveals gear
chests on the minimap
for one in-game day
giving you a pretty lucky day on your
journey as you explore hogwarts and the
surrounding areas so that's in game day
that's not like a full real world 24
hours this is just the recipe though
you'll still need to make the most of
your potions lessons and the room of
requirement potion stations to brew this
bottle of liquid luck
by choosing one of our upgraded editions
of hogwarts legacy players will gain
access to additional in-game cosmetics
including the only way to get a flying
thestral mount in the game
the digital deluxe edition also has 72
hour early access and a digital crosston
upgrade allowing you to upgrade from the
ps4 version to the ps5 all pre-orders
for hogwarts legacy will get the onyx
hippogriff mount so reiterating a little
bit about the pre-order stuff because it
did get kind of crazy hogwarts legacy
deluxe and digital deluxe edition okay
so they've added
the felix felices here for the um
playstation version
also
the um
uh showing the thestral again which we
we've already seen that dark arts
cosmetics 72 hours dark arts battle
arena and then this little area here so
this is the hard copy deluxe
and then the
digital deluxe gets also gets the dark
arts garrison hat don't ask me why it's
only for the digital i have no idea but
that's how they're doing it
okay
and then we have the collector's edition
let's see here
looks like nothing new has been added to
this one
which like they're still advertising
this so do they have more to sell
because
nobody's been able to get one except
from gamestop and just a few people got
in on best buy and a few on amazon
hogwarts legacy launches on february 10
2023 on ps4 and ps5
ladies and gentlemen
that was a lot of news
that was a lot of news
all right so what do you guys think
what do you guys think about all that
stuff there what stood out the most
somebody was saying that people are 50
50 on it
why are they why are they 50 50 on it
what's the what's the 50 50.
day night cycles confirmed yeah exactly
in game day will be [ __ ]
shadow got it will be five minutes
before ron gets tired
oh man
i understood that reference exactly
dude i just can't believe that we get
our own shop
is there a way i can just like put this
on replay
wait is that what this button does
autoplay is on
yeah anyway we'll we're going to watch
it again in in slow motion here
do you think there will be other shops
that's a great question retro guy gaming
that's what i'm trying to figure out
[Music]
will there be other shops that maybe
aren't as cool and without the better
rates or just none for a year i agree
like that
that seems like a really big thing but i
think your second point there gets at
the fact that it won't be the only one
because if it can sell at better rates
then that would imply
that there's somewhere else for
everybody to sell everyone else to sell
at
right
unless it's like one of those games
where you go into a shop and you can buy
and sell like
you sell just to the vendors
but i don't think so
i don't think so
tone 80 dude i'm so happy to get the pc
and wife uh ps5 collectors edition
owning a shop right like this the owning
a shop thing is another one of those
pieces that is just like
makes me stretch out what i was
expecting for the scope of this game
even more if that was possible
like are you kidding me we're gonna be
able to have our own shops
like i feel like that was one of those
things that people were just
almost like a pipe dream like a joking
like you never expect
people are like yeah i'm going to
graduate and then i'm going to
go into my wizard career and i'm going
to run a shop in hogsmeade
dylan with the 20
super chat dylan
dude thank you so much man for showing
the love with the super chat very much
appreciated
dylan another another one like like
johnny always showing love congrats on
the 30k
watch the video with captions yeah
that's what uh that's what oni was
saying yeah
we need to do that
i'm gonna play it through one more time
normal and then uh we'll watch it back
through with sound and everything
i'm just i'm reading comments here i
wanna see what you guys think make jokes
and chat with cool peeps
[Music]
child labor
having a shop would be a cool way to
earn galleons outside of being paid for
quests right i agree
fine arkham knight find owning a shop
kind of weird see that's what i don't
know if i would say weird but like
definitely unexpected
but then again like that there's
somewhat of a precedent for that right
like fred and george
somewhat of a precedent in harry potter
fred and george opened up their own shop
and eventually left
hogwarts to do that as a career
well
at least george did
rip fred r.i.p
yeah right like
i still say like my dream game
harry potter game dream sequel would be
like
a wizard career game
all right i'm gonna mute for one second
so you guys don't have to hear me blow
my nose
[Music]
all right just to give you all an idea
man how bad my allergies get
don't worry it's not it's not gross or
anything
so
this is one of those little
kleenex boxes you know
i opened this last night
and it's gone
and it's gone
what can you buy with money in the game
besides cosmetics yeah i mean that
remains to be seen right sinjin retro
yeah
it's very difficult like you guys are so
good sinjin with like making good
comments that i i'll i'll see one and
it's like oh dude we gotta
i go off on that exactly
my apologies guys plum bob kingdom uh
yes it's one year one year for the
exclusivity on the quest which i wonder
did it say anything about the felix
i wonder if the felix is one year too
no it specifically
says the quest
but i gotta think there's gonna be
the felix one too you gotta think
but okay another thing that this like
another amazing thing about this
this is two now of just
side quests
that we've seen like
not even relating to the main game
dude
marcus hey marcus thanks for subbing to
the channel and looks like nico with
another gifted membership
nico man showing some love with the
the fellow viewers thank you so much
use the shop to sell all the stuff that
doesn't look evil wonder if you can
create your own clothing looks
oh i like that idea dutch
tom snipes gets one of the gifted
members nice
like this is something i would have
never expected
i would have never expected
amir says weirdly enough i heard
you could like hear the sneeze the uh
well not the sneeze but the blowing of
the nose
love this so much
you talk about the trailer
sell the shop without dealing with the
evil dude and then send hagrid to the
bad guy say you're a wizard hair
oh man let's see where things go
oh my gosh jake with a an injury there
yikes
nightwing i'm sure you can unlock the
recipe in game but playstation gets
automatically yeah i that's what i'm
starting to believe as well
[Music]
creating your own clothes
[Music]
right
no carol no
no cat in the room just my dog
it's like once or twice a year man i'll
have this moment where i just have like
a really bad
like
really bad bout with allergies i'm
another super chat coming in from
leisure not leisure not with the 10
super chat thank you so much glad to
finally catch one of your live streams
what is your hogwarts legacy character
name going to be
dude that's a good question i don't know
if i'll use my real name or if i use
retro
i mean it's either it's got to be
jonathan or retro one of the two
then last name i still don't know if
we'll get to choose our last name or if
it's going to be
if it's going to be set you know
but thank you so much leisure not for
showing support with the super chat
[Music]
pets in the game pets are pretty much
confirmed no caps
because of the um
the trailer that showed
the whole like
magical menagerie that we'll be able to
have and it showed the little nasal in
there and some other animals in there
last name
wrecking tour
the name's wrecking tour retro wrecking
tour
yeah if we
forget to choose the last name of the
like mr recontour
mr potter
mr rackentor
what are you doing down there
students are not allowed
can we choose names that people refer to
us as like a fault see colonel that's
part of the reason i that i think our
last name will be set
so that they could um
so that they could just like have that
running
you know so they have the voiceover for
that
and then we could actually hear our at
least our last name being set again
because think i mean that's
like last names
i guess that's maybe a british thing of
how
how often the last names are used like
think about i mean harry refers to it's
mcgonagall snape dumbledore those are
all their last names and then their
people are constantly calling him potter
you know
come here
pc requirements for the game is kinda
high sir archibald says yeah i don't i
don't know enough about the tech specs
to be able to say but i have
i have seen a few people saying that
small buttons yeah i definitely will if
they're gonna be there i mean if they do
something there i will for sure react
all right let's watch this again or macy
says yeah i went to private school as a
kid we call all the teachers by the last
name there we go
yep malfoy they always call him malfoy
but then it's like you got neville and
luna
harry ron hermione
crab and goyle though that's last names
so it's like people of authority and
people they don't like
because there's like sheamus let's see
fleur
cedric
yes it's like the students harry doesn't
like
last name
[Music]
yeah dominic yes we just uh we just read
through the playstation blog exactly
all right so some people were telling me
to watch through it again with uh
captions on so we're gonna do that now
so let's go and turn the captions on
here
scroll back to the beginning and here we
go so if you guys are just joining we've
already watched the trailer through
twice
but um now we're going to watch through
with captions and actually this time i
might let's go ahead and do like a full
breakdown
ah duarte with the super chat
coming in clutch right click and have
loop there we go i knew there had to be
a way to do that
thank you so much
channel member
name myself
hairless sweeter
what
you know what's kind of weird my friend
likes my
grill oh maybe mean girl girl cousin
requirements would probably be lower the
reason i think it was delayed ah
interesting
oh that yeah
well malfoy and those they say granger
watch it on the playstation channel not
hogwarts legacy what
okay
okay let's see
right here
all right we got captions on make sure
we're at the
highest quality
make sure we got sound okay
all right wait let me record this here
people of the internet welcome back we
are
nah cut i don't like that
people of the internet retrorecords who
are here and now we are taking a deep
dive in the brand new hogwarts legacy
playstation exclusive haunted hogs meet
shopquest that is right it is exclusive
to playstation for one year we are going
to deep dive now break down the full
trailer and see what all we can find
because there is a lot here guys just in
the first viewing i caught several
different things that i want to
highlight so we're watching it with
captions here they're going to be some
interesting things that we're going to
find there as well but let's dive in
okay so we get the first shot of
hogsmeade and the music again like i'm
just dude the music sets the tone so
well and i love this night shot
and you get i mean is it is it snowing
or raining i think it's i think it's
like a light snow
so we're seeing hogsmeade at night it
kind of has this wet sort of shimmering
look to it
but it just the music really sets the
mood right away sets the mood
okay and then we have this kind of
little fly-in view here
we've got the hogs head here so this is
like we've seen this kind of area before
and then we get this shot of honeydukes
we've got a student here saying hello
madame mason so this name cassandra
mason was actually leaked a while back
on imdb this is something that we found
on the harry potter game subreddit a
long time ago cassandra mason and then
the other one was helen thistlewood many
are guessing that helen thistlewood will
be the hufflepuff not hufflepuff the um
herbology professor i think that makes a
lot of sense so now we finally know that
cassandra mason is actually a
real character as well so we start
zooming into a different area of
hogsmeade here we've got honeydukes and
what looks like these little like
pumpkins or something bouncing in the
window here let's go ahead and play it a
little bit more
hello madam mason i understand you have
a shop to sell i understand you have a
shop to sell all right so let's back
this up a little bit
take a look at this wizard right here
okay so this must be cassandra mason
right here or which rather
looks like they've got the quill here
writing something down there's a lock on
the door
remember we saw the locks on the door on
the doors in the asmr videos and we
wondered what's going on with those we
see the lock here
who knows if we'll be able to learn
alohomora to unlock some of the other
ones
but here with this one right i think
this one is
we sign over
i guess they're selling the shop to us i
wonder if we'll have to earn enough
currency in-game to buy it
before we can actually uh take it over
i think you will find my germs quite
generous i think you will find my terms
quite generous oh man okay and we've got
a lot here in this shot but before that
i don't want to miss anything from the
one before it
let's back up here i think
okay this looks like
pretty much just the door here
it's so much harder to when i've got the
light shining on me for the camera it's
so much harder to make out
all right so i don't think we see
anything in the dark area
now this shot though
okay there's a lot here we've got this
right here says no trolls
we have this sort of interesting symbol
right here
it's got a line going and then somewhat
of an x is that three brooms or three
wands
is this like the handle of a wand or is
that meant to be a broom
i'm not really sure and then we have a
hand here possibly a
hand of glory
another one of these things over here oh
you guys told me what that was in the
last
that's the thing we see something very
similar in the common room trailers that
the characters walk by and can spin
you guys told me last time what that was
called i completely forgot and then
there's something over here that says or
and something
yeah we don't get a better look at it
though unfortunately
what's the catch okay
now things start to get crazy
there's a treasure chest right there and
then these little
dolls or dummies whatever you want to
call them
we saw these things
in the autodesk session so if you guys
didn't watch the autodesk trailer
that was a breakdown of some of the more
technical aspects of hogwarts legacy
and in the character creation area i
guess i should clarify though the
character creation for avalanche's side
of things not what the player's side
will look like but when they're building
characters it showed a little bit of
what that looks like and we saw these
things right here these mannequins
and a lot of people just thought oh
that's probably just for their design of
you know helping them design the
characters that's kind of just like a
model they used
but no
they're actually here
in the game
uh instead and they're going to come to
life here in a second and kind of go
crazy a little bit
but we have something shining over here
in the left as well we got the chest
right there in the middle
and then lots of spider webs
or maybe just like old kind of dusty
cobwebs instead who knows though man
there might be more spiders in here too
and then what is this object over here
on the right
it's got kind of a gold goldish look to
it let's see if we get any closer on any
of this
nope immediately cuts away you are wise
to be wary mason says
we have a broom over here on the left we
have a portrait here
portrait here definitely a wizard
because they're holding a wand holding
them on with their left hand
and then we're kind of zooming in on the
chest right here
don't really uh interesting little just
looks like some kind of floral pattern
here
why is your mistress selling the shop
why is your mistress selling the shop
so cassandra mason's mistress
or or
could they be asking at someone else no
i think they're it was mason talking i
think they're almost certainly talking
to mason here
why is your mistress selling the shop
oh come on i want it to get back right
around
right there
come on frame by frame it takes a little
longer but then you don't miss certain
details so we've got a ravenclaw this
time so the player character is a
ravenclaw here and whatever that chest
that we were just walking up to this is
clearly the same room because we could
see these kind of on the right side so
now they have opened the chest and she
looks very distressed by what she has
found in there
very very distressed
the mannequins are
definitely creepy it's your mistress
selling the shop
she has had rotten bad luck
she has had rotten bad luck with the
last few tenants
penny
new name
new name
so the person talking now is someone
named penny
that might be one you guys wanted me to
watch with subtitles okay so we have
cassandra mason and now we have someone
called penny uh sounds like a younger
voice
i don't know
and then this then they go all inception
on us i mean
walking down the hall and it just
completely shifts right there then this
wall just goes flying the other way
i can see this being a very like
psychological
thriller type area
where you're just gonna have to be on
your toes
those who came before you festidio
okay so we've got penny we've got fast
studio
if there's something significant about
either of those names that i should know
you guys let me know those who came
before you just could not seem just
could not seem to escape the darkness oh
so we gotta it's like something we're
gonna be trapped trying to get out of
here
will you oh my gosh that's so creepy
watch this shot right
there
dude
i think that's what they use for the
thumbnail on the video
oh man all right sorry gotta we gotta
pause again
interesting so you guys are saying
there's a penny in
hogwarts legacy or
hogwarts mystery a house elf huh okay
so is that our name is that what
everyone will call us student
you're probably right
you're probably right
all right let's move forward here
okay and then looks like a continuation
of that scene our character takes off
running they're right behind us
whoa look at the movement on that though
that was kind of a weird zombie movement
from that mannequin
watch it's like over here on the right
and then it just sort of almost like a
little teleport
not a teleport but a lunge and then who
is this
oh dude there are spiders whoops
yep
yep those spider webs
uh we were warned man we were worn by
the spider webs okay
is that a beard
is that a beard or is that long hair or
both
beard long hair or both i think it's
i think it might be both a beard and
long hair
oh man is it fastidio is it merlin
is it slytherin
because the other trailer with sebastian
that one focused on slytherin i mean my
first like just initial reaction i
thought it looked similar to the
ravenclaw statue that we saw in the
ravenclaw common room but i don't think
it's ravenclaw
dude we'll have to play around with that
um like the exposure on that
and so
then we get more spiders
dude
there are a lot of arachnophobe
arachnophobics out there
i feel for you
i feel for you because it seems like
this game is not shying away from it
then you have this lantern another
creepy i mean just
hovering over nothing we have this sort
of star-like symbol here
and then right in the middle of them
we saw protego there briefly
and then another uh dude that's an
awesome spell
i'm not really sure what spell that
would be you guys know any guesses off
the top of your head i don't think
incendio because it has this kind of
like fanning effect where it goes out
in a circle all the way around
that is pretty cool though
watch your step
watch your step
evil laughter
oh man i love it
evil laughter
well let me know what you guys think
down in the comments below as always
thank you all so much for watching i'll
talk to you again soon
we're not ending the live stream guys
that's just for uh for youtube later
fiend fire yeah could be fiendfire could
be all right let's loop this video now
i'm gonna bring back our other
happy music
upgraded incendio incendio maxima i
could see that honestly
vestidio sounds like a poltergeist he
kind of does
or a ghost maybe
[Music]
where is this huge shop in hogsmeade
never seen it before
um i mean we're not really sure right
we know that it looks like
let's see
we know that it looks like this
or at least this is meant to be a
representation of it
[Music]
i just can't believe that it's a whole
dungeon though
a whole entire dungeon for this shop
by the way we just had a dollar ninety
nine from jayden
jane thank you so much for the uh looks
like a sticker sneak peek
nice thank you so much for your support
with the suit i think they're called
super stickers on youtube
this comment here please don't go too
much into the horror genre sincerely i
think people are starting to get a
little bit worried
because everything we've seen so far is
so dark
in chandler's blog post though to be
fair he did talk about
the darker side of hogwarts legacy
so
i don't think we should panic not yet
i mean let's be honest they know this is
what people want
people love the dark arts man they're
obsessed with the dark arts
as long as i have a
i do not even know how to pronounce that
jay the wizard
fiend fire in fury but re-skinned nah i
don't think in fury
now because we we see in fury
elsewhere
hey have a good night eddie thanks for
stopping by
maybe the shop is
oh yeah we sell whatever you get yeah if
you have the option to just sell the
whole shop
when you don't uh
you're like i don't want to deal with
this
my guess is that we will the way that we
will take ownership of the shop
we'll have to buy it but it will be
it'll be like really cheap because it's
haunted so mason's just trying to mata
mason's just trying to get out of there
my terms quite generous so they're going
to give us a good deal
because they don't want any part of it
students like what's the catch
so mason's kind of telling us
why is your mister selling the shop
so
mason is penny's mistress
so the character is asking penny why is
the mister selling the shop
[Music]
those who came before you and then this
is a totally different voice
oh man
what are we going to do with our beasts
when we graduate hogwarts
what do you mean i don't think we're
going to graduate hogwarts not in this
game
[Music]
i don't think so
yeah i think this is definitely more i
mean the haunted house right they're
calling it a haunted house they're going
with that haunted
vibe these mannequins coming to life
clearly there will be
i think you guys could be spot on with
like a poltergeist maybe a poltergeist
behind it maybe a
maybe it's a dark wizard i think it'd be
cooler though a poltergeist is a really
good idea i like that
i like that a lot
star geezer tim what is up dude welcome
shadow guided
throwing up the slytherin
icon there doubt it's fiend fire that
didn't change shape i can yeah fiend
fire is just like so it's almost
uncontrollable
it just goes crazy
that's what happened with uh
was it goyle
and deathly hallows
what'd you think of the new
trailer tim if you've watched it yet
being able to own my own shop and so
many mechanics makes me question what
exactly nightly nerd exactly
this is the second time i've had my mind
kind of blown like that the first was
the the big
gameplay reveal trailer
when they
we learned that we get like all that
stuff inside the
room of requirement
with the um
menageries and all that like that blew
my mind i did not expect that
now we're learning that this piece here
this is an optional
dungeon
just just amazing
how big is this game you guys
stezza may be a way for us to take
income so we can buy stuff in hikes mead
yeah yeah
p
peeves in a trench coat
star hopper on the hogsmeade walls paper
you get
from connecting your fan account there's
a shop right at the top of the village
wondering for the same one okay we can
look at that let's see
let's see here
working on it come on oh i'm still